when I was a shoe salesman I don't do
things with a half-ass intent behind
them so my thing was I'm gonna be the
best shoe salesman I'm eventually gonna
work for Nike that's that's how I'm
gonna work for Nike corporate and I'm
gonna take this thing and spin it into
something big
right so I have big goal and within but
why not use this when you worked in the
shoe store did you ever hook up with a
woman who's that you were trying on
shoes and the shoe store for a woman
attractive woman walks and she says you
did of course you go back home and her
and bang her oh well not that night but
eventually it would happen of course we
talked I mean that's part of the beauty
of the job meeting people and having
people coming in see here's think it's
all about spitting the shoe talk sweetie
what do you do do you supinate do you
produce you would you really care about
their feet you know let me see you do
that amazing feet first of all there's
like a creepy when you oh yeah hot
arches you said that to a woman arches
you have very nice arches and a good
thing about arches is you're protecting
yourself from future shin splints let me
get you for you I know you'll like it
good lord you're charming me every day I
kind of want to sleep it right you could
see Kevin Hart and ride along too